-Now, we all love our pets,
and every pet owner thinks
that their pet is the best.
Well, I wanted to see
if that was true,
so it's time for "Why Is
Your Pet Better Than Me?"
Here we go.
-♪ Why is your pet ♪
♪ Better than me,
better than me? ♪
♪♪
-Alright,
let's meet our first pet.
Hello, hi. What is your name
and where are you from?
-Hey, I'm Miranda from Durham,
North Carolina.
-Yeah, Durham. I love it. Hey.
Miranda, thank you
for being on the show.
I see -- Oh. Ooh.
I see a cat behind you.
I'm assuming that's the pet.
What is your cat's --
Ooh. That's a pretty good trick
right there.
Just flops down
and smacks the tail.
Is that...?
-Exactly.
This is Bruce.
-Bruce!
Bruce, hey, buddy.
And what does Bruce do?
Why is your pet better than me?
-So, Bruce can sometimes
turn the light off.
-I love the "sometimes."
[ Laughter ]
What do you mean Bruce
can sometimes turn --
Oh, you're gone.
Alright. So, Bruce.
Alright, Bruce.
Can you do it? Can you
turn the light off, Bruce?
Bruce? Uh-oh.
Bruce? Oh.
[ Laughter ]
This is leaning towards the --
Oh, he's thinking about it.
He's thinking about it.
Come on, Bruce. You got this.
Come on, Bruce. Yep.
Come on, Buddy.
Come on, Bruce. You got -- Yes.
What is that?
No -- Oh. Yes, Bruce. Come on.
[ Laughter ]
D-Do you want to
maybe prop Bruce up maybe
or get Bruce to --
I think -- Here you go.
Bruce.
Show me what you got, Bruce!
Come on, buddy! I see it.
I see it. Look at that.
I see it, Bruce! Come on!
Come on, buddy!
Maybe get -- [ Laughs ]
Come on, Bruce!
He -- Can we -- Can we move the
light switch down lower maybe?
I just -- [ Laughs ]
Oh, my God. Alright.
There you go.
[ Laughs ]
Alright. Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
That's fantastic.
Thank you, Bruce.
[ Laughs ]
There you go -- Bruce,
the cat that can
sometimes
turn the light switch off.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Now let's get to our next pet.
Uh, hello. Welcome. What is your
name and where are you from?
Look at this.
-My name is Mike.
I'm from Keyport, New Jersey.
-Oh, I love -- Now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
New Jersey in the house.
Thank you, buddy.
Now, what do you have there?
What are you holding?
What is your -- What is that?
-This is my hedgehog, Tuck.
-Oh, my goodness.
I didn't even know you could
have a hedgehog as a pet.
That's amazing.
And what does your shirt say?
-"The Hogfather."
-There you go. Of course. Yes.
The hedgehog. It's a hedgehog.
Now, already
I think he's better than me,
but what do you have set up,
and please show me
why is your pet better than me.
-So, Tuck is
an American Hedgehog Warrior,
and he's going to hopefully
navigate this little
obstacle course I have behind me
and ultimately end up in
our mini ball pit over here.
And I'm not so sure you'd
be able to do that, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-You'd be right. You'd be right.
I don't know if I could.
But let's see what Tuck does.
Our first pet,
the pressure really got to him.
So let's see.
-[ Chuckles ]
-American Hedgehog --
-Alright, and if you don't mind,
I think I'm gonna do
a little hog casting
if that's okay with you.
-Oh, my God.
Look at this.
This is an amazing production.
Alright, buddy.
-Yeah, he's making his way.
-Yep.
-Making his way way through
Pool Noodle Bars we have here.
-Has he been hanging out
with Bruce the cat at all?
Feels like they've been out
drinking all night.
-I know. I know.
He's usually
a little quicker than this.
-Yeah. Well, pressure's on.
I could do this.
[ Laughter ]
But he looks like
he's making a move maybe.
I think.
-He might be.
He might also
be going to the bathroom.
They tend to do that a lot.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Give me one second.
Let me restart.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Tuck, here we go, buddy.
Here we go.
-Let me show you the course real
quick while we're waiting here.
-Yeah, might as well
at this point.
Tuck definitely hasn't seen it,
so yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, oh, oh. Wait. Wait.
A little action.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah. This is it.
This is good.
Tuck --
-Wait a sec.
[ Laughter ]
-He's stuck
at that point right there.
That's a tricky...
He did -- [ Laughs ]
This is what he did last time.
Yeah, he goes to that spot and
he just kind of camps out there.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. I don't know.
-No, it's fine. I think
that he's comfortable there.
Let's give it up for Tuck,
'cause he did --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think you did a good job.
Let's meet our last pet here.
Uh, hey. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hi, my name's Lucy, and
I'm from Grantham in England.
-Hey! We love it! Ah!
Thank you for watching us.
Now, Lucy,
this is a great night for you,
because the other pets
haven't really shown
and proven to us
why they're better than me.
They are very cute.
-[ Indistinct ]
-Yeah, so the pressure's on.
Who is there with you?
Who do you have there?
-This is Trip Hazard.
[ Laughter ]
-Trip Hazard.
-Trip for short.
-[ Laughs ] Trip Hazard.
What does Trip Hazard do?
-He closes the door,
but he's too small to do it,
so he's got his own unique way
of doing it.
-Okay. Here we go.
This is Trip Hazard.
Can we get a drum roll maybe
for Trip Hazard?
He's gonna close the door.
Trip Hazard. Trip Hazard.
-Close the door.
Shut the door.
-This is -- This has potential!
This has potential!
This is -- Yes!
That's my -- That's a good dog!
Yes! Yes!
Great job! Lucy, thank you!
Great job, Trip Hazard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you to
all of our talented pets.
If you think you have a pet
that's better than me,
I want to see it.
Go to tonightshow.com/
whyisyourpetbetterthanme
to submit a video of your pet.